I'd like to be very focused on this
lecture because we're going to be
working on a positional chess today okay
so I will be showing you one of my games
played in 2008 at the Chicago Open and
in fact this game was a very important
game I was playing a grandmaster Parag
WA from Philippines a former over 2600
player and in this game I was black and
I needed to win so I can you know
continue my lead and I eventually did
and helping to win this big tournament
in Chicago so I'm playing with the black
pieces and it's always a task when
you're playing a strong player what to
play and what strategy to choose whether
or not just try to equalize try to play
something that will offer you some
chances as well to play for win so it's
after spending some time deciding on a
strategy for this game which I usually I
like to go to the game prepared I don't
like to just go to the game and when he
makes the move I start thinking of what
I need to play I kind of try to decide
already in which opening because we have
choices I can play the French I can play
caro-kann do many different openings so
I like to decide before the game that I
know okay if you place this move this is
how I'm going to play in this game and
usually when you decide on something I
recommend to go with it don't just
decide and then go and then when you're
about to play the opening then you start
doubting yourself and trying or maybe I
do this maybe I guess so just try to
decide before the game yes
it happens it happens quite often I mean
I did a lecture a couple of weeks ago it
was on the game against Grandmaster
traigo both and that was played in the
World Cup 2009 and we knew the pairings
so he knew he's gonna play me like three
weeks in advance and I knew it also so I
prepared against him extensively looking
all his games and preparing he will play
sloth defence nimzo-indian and suddenly
when I went all the way to Siberia to
play this tournament and we arrived the
first game I'm playing with the white
pieces I play d4 he goes f5
I couldn't find a single game in a
database that he plays f5 so this
happens quite a lot people surprise but
not always it's going to be really good
just some like just you surprise
somebody you're going to win a game so
he did that but it didn't turn out good
for him
he lost in like 27 moves so but you know
you really if you're surprising somebody
you should have knowledge you know yeah
yeah anyway yeah it was a you know very
interesting very very long match against
him I mean I eventually won but it was
this they called a marathon match
because we played 16 games so it was
like it was equal and then he would win
one I would win one yeah finally I won
the final score of that match because
somebody needed to win to advance to the
next stage so finally I want 9 9 to 7
that match so that's the longest the
history the longest history of this
matches you know so it's just like so
anyway so yeah you have to really know
about opening when you're going to
surprise somebody so it's a you know so
he played efore which I expected so I
played d6 a little bit of a surprise
because you know most people know that I
play the French defense and but
sometimes I could play this opening and
this is called a check perk so it's not
if I play g6 it's just going to be the
normal perk defense so but I played c6
my coach taught me this international
master Nathanial back in Armenia
long time ago maybe when I was 10 12
years old he taught me this opening and
I've always played in the childhood but
then I stopped playing for a while but I
nowadays I still play it sometimes so
you could see that you know in my games
you know I use it it's it's an opening
that lot of players playing with why
they're not like you play c6 and that
they're not so familiar with it even if
they know they only know a few moves but
you really have to know more about this
opening if you get advantage so I've
played many games with this and have
some really good results with it
actually my winning percentage is very
high and almost like maybe one or two
losses entire time so I mean it's a high
score well with this opening but I don't
play it all the time because against
when I play very very high rated
opponents it's a bit risky so but in
this game I decided to play against him
so he played f4 and this is the best
move in my opinion and they move that
white needs to play if he wants to fight
for advantage anything else he plays
it's just going to be a normal game I
think about with about the roughly equal
chances but this is the move that you
know principled move to play so it looks
like for a moment white has the control
of the center and he's going to just
develop his pieces and according to our
principles he's just going to have a
nice position but it's not so simple
because we play Queen a5 here and now my
turret is 90 X e4 and I've had people
actually play Knight f3 here strong
player Ceylon you know I took the pawn
on e4 so missing another threat so
remember main idea is just to pin and
now trading 94 so let me ask you who is
familiar with this opening ok Ben is
probably familiar with this but who else
except been anybody else familiar with
this opening like if you work let's say
I'm playing you I play this move Queen
f5 what would you do here let's say you
know the threat threat is 90 X e4 right
then
three different moves you can play here
Bishop d2 Bishop d2 is a move it's one
of the main moves any other alternatives
well see the thing is if you go ninety
two you're not really stopping the strap
so the thread is still there okay so you
Bishop d3 correct yeah this is the most
popular move this is what you played so
we'll look at that another move here is
a five they play so these are the three
moves that you know he can play so if
you're looking for an opening it's a
little bit unorthodox but still very
very interesting you may want to you
know do a little bit research and you're
going to see this game today and maybe
add this to your robot opening
repertoire okay so you can have your
main openings but on the side you know
you can have this sometimes you can play
as a surprise factor so now I'm
threatening to take the pawn so you
played the most most people I tell you
going to play Bishop d3 this is what
most people did against me so now you
play e5 it's very important move and
they play Knight f3
there are other alternatives here to
play for a while but the best move is 93
for example I've had this position my
recent game in this opening was against
Stephen Zurich as a former world
champion and I don't think he was very
familiar with this opening so when I
played him in the National Open last
year Las Vegas he took to camp laid 93
this move and this is already not so
good for why because I just played
Bishop g4 and he choked and blocked to
play let's see if we can find a best
move in this position
so let's say you playing with the black
pieces here what would you do here okay
well but that's that's actually what he
wants you to do then look you move the
bishop twice one two you lose a temple
right there and then you're going to
allow him to develop another piece and
now we move the Queen again twice right
so this could really very quickly
backfire yeah after Bishop go for if you
look at just look at the position you
can already tell that Bach is in trouble
because White has four pieces developed
and your queen is under attack that
means you have to move again losing
another temple so you're in big trouble
okay so it's very dangerous to go for
this okay so you don't want to do that
you want to take back only five with a
knight in this position okay because
when you take back with the knight unite
will be very well placed and remember
Knight will block his isolated pawn as
well usually you want to use a knight to
block opponent Palmilla 9f to d7 I
played in this game and then I took the
pond anyway this is another very
interesting game in-sample maybe I will
show this game as well you know as a
continuation to the same topic you know
but this is already good for black
because I just take back with a knight
and then I put my other night on d7 and
dark square Bishop comes out and I
Castle so I have a pretty comfortable
position here and he cannot do that much
here okay I think he did that he played
here I took and then I take back with a
knight important I want to take back
with the night because then I want to
have a centralized piece okay so anyway
so my opponent you know he played here
now you develop a knight okay
now there's a very nice trap I want to
show you I have one actually a lot of
games with this trap you're usually in
the Blitz game some rapid games bit some
strong players actually so I like you to
know this trap so there is a movie eat
XD for here I've played this movie in
many occasions actually I prefer to play
9b d7 here but you know I've played this
move before many games and I've analyzed
this move so he takes now you play this
strange kind of looking move Queen b6
you move the Queen again so they're
wasting a tempo but again it's not so
easy for white to move here so you
cannot develop your Bishop because your
BT pump will be hanging right so most
people play here and I played here now
I'm getting to play a four so usually in
this position they play two moves you
know most people play a four but when
they play a food you just simply develop
your Bishop and Castle and then you have
this idea of Knight a 694 you have a
good square for your knight it's a good
outpost step for tonight so that's why
some players think Black is just playing
really bad so they just want to take
advantage of it so they go here now you
continue playing a4 and again they just
you know they theological yeah then
you're making some pawn moves they're
developing it suddenly in this position
you go Queen before looks like again
what is black - and I'm gonna just keep
on moving the Queen you know it's going
to lose now they play a tree and then
and white is just you know thinking okay
I win this game I trap the Queen see if
I had this position happen many times
must have at least 110 games with with
block not tournament against the blades
and wrap it in so I cake so he takes my
queen check now if it comes up I take
another rope so I already have a minor
piece I took in a rock so some people go
here quickly thinking okay we go here in
Castle and I play Bishop g4 and they
resign
so it's a good trap to know because if
you're playing this especially in blitz
you can definitely win a few games like
this okay and now it's just so you take
on do you want to take on h1 if only a
fool is a necessary move but again they
have to know this and during the game
it's very hard to know this you know
sequences so yeah but I'm in this
position I mean if you analyze this
position computer will say why it is a
little bit better but it's playable I
played it before you go Bishop e7 castle
ninety six ninety four okay yes uh-huh
did you anticipated there before you
yeah of course you have to calculate
that yeah of course yeah of course
otherwise you can just make all the
smooth with the Queen without analyzing
the position because you will simply
lose your queen at the game so I mean I
saw up to the move Bishop g4 that I have
this move otherwise it's just it's just
really bad play by black but so yeah you
play Bishop e7 here and Castle Knight a
six maybe white is a little bit better
but it's it's game so but yeah I played
this 9b d7 move here so he castles okay
Bishop e7 King h1 prophylactic move I
Castle now I played here
and now in this position after you
played Bishop III I want to give you a
chance to find the next move okay it's
black he just played Bishop III okay so
you go you're only going to be finding
the moves for black in this game so
black to play what would be the best
move in this position it's a hard move
to find but it's a necessary move in
this kind of positions if you have an
opportunity also you want to play this
move well 9 to g4 it's C this is just a
one with one of you yeah it's just a one
move threat it's you make one move
threat then he goes here and your knight
is kind of misplaced here so then he can
he can maybe move you back and so
well if I be five is a move that we want
to play not always we get to play this
move because sometimes they put the pawn
on a four but here he didn't so here I
played b5 now I played B 5v5 is the
right move here because with power on b5
in these positions we have more space
and most important thing is you always
have this before threat idea and you
have a place to develop your Bishop okay
so sometimes they don't let you do that
but in this position I manage that
because if it takes I had to make sure
this line works for me this is the key
line here he takes and for example if I
don't have this move here then it's a
bad position for me but thanks to this
move here I am I'm better maybe so
what's the move now before excellent not
only you move the knight back now you
increase the pressure on this pawn so he
has to go back and then you simply take
take and again you reach a position like
this where you have you always want to
have a knight blocking that pawn Knight
is the best piece to block pounds like
that okay and now his light-square
bishop is passive and it's a comfortable
position for blackish you play Bishop
probably Bishop e6 rook 88 and it's good
so he played after I played b5 he played
Queen d2 developing move but what do you
think is it just developing or he has a
threat now
so just developing or he has some threat
exactly is a typical threat okay when
opponent has a queen on a five you put
the Queen under your 1395 for example
you go Bishop e7 95 attacking your queen
you take his screen he has a in between
check okay very important between check
you have to go away and then it takes it
okay good and you know it well if you
allow this then the only thing to do is
to go back but this is when you lose
your Bishop it's it's not good in this
positions because he has a center and
two bishops so this would be a much
better game for white so my plate here
what should I do
another typical move now needs to be
played
we'll be visited by
move back on d8 yeah but look if you put
a bishop here this will you know
disconnect you know the communication
with the rooks
and it doesn't look that good yeah
Knight takes here no not this well the
problem with this move now he goes your
queen might be a little bit awkward
after a three a and this before palm I
get a little bit pressure too so this
next move is actually really necessary
otherwise I'm just worse in this opening
one of the key factors is you have to
make sure you keep control of the e5
square so you need to control the e5
square this is very important okay which
move yeah but he's got a lot of pressure
here this is the kid he always going to
have a lot of he's putting lots of
pressure here so we have to control it
we can't go away Queen c7 yes
it's well about the same thread same
thread yeah be careful so I went here
very good and here my opponent should
have probably played rook a you want
something you know solid it's a game
unclear game so he plays a four he's
trying to take advantage of my early
push b5 so my next move it's necessary I
mean I can protect on b5 I can play six
because he just takes the XE just takes
takes you take the block so he has to go
before now
ninety-two and now a very important move
you have to find if you don't play this
book you're going to be slightly worse
but after the next move it's at least
equal perhaps black has the initiative
think think don't work this is not just
the regular move this is its yeah this
this idea in this opening in this
opening this this idea works I've done
it in different positions but it has to
be exactly like this the pawn structure
so think about a little bit ah
okay c5 see if I've probably not so good
because you just let's see
why c5 is not good maybe takes just
creating we created a lot of weeks query
this d5 I know the c-4 is a threat here
but perhaps even just b3 maybe can play
here so I'm not sure about this D Phi
square so the strong of here is very
good
yes D if I see I'm trying to take
advantage of the fact that his efore
squared is not very well protected and
he has his pieces are placed this way so
I can have this threat of link efore see
basically I'm breaking the center now if
I can break the center exchange some of
these pawns then I can have some
initiative very strong move d5 let's
take a look now so many different
captures so we have to now analyze dis
captures so first capture just very bad
losing y pawn fork so this is just the
first thing out he could take with the
night this is a possibility but then we
just take with night attacking his Queen
and if it goes back we just go f6 remove
the strong Knight takes we take and I
think buckets maybe slightly better here
because my knight is still very strong
I'll go Bishop d6 bouquet e1 and I have
a nice development and so like it's
maybe a little better so he plays he
played pawn takes he took with this pawn
which is natural to take to open up to
file for the rook
now what do you think I should do here
because nobody long work
well you can't blame antique c4 but then
he just moves his Queen and I mean he's
got that strong pot only five I like to
get some position but he doesn't have
this strong pulse in my territory and I
have a way to do that here
although he takes on d5
think about it you already know this
idea of playing efore right forking
those pieces for a moment think about
this if let's say he's not attacking
your knight on f6 what would you do
of course you take on e4 because you
want to fork him so now he takes it
looks like a problem we cannot take his
pieces because it's going to take he's
going to take but we just take now for a
moment we're down a piece but next one
we're going to get a piece back and as
you can see no more strong Center for
him okay the reason he took with the F
pawn to be able to have open file for
the rook okay you could have get the
same position with a pawn on f4 but I
think this is better version for white
you know he has a central pawn and open
file so now he plays Bishop f4 attacking
the Queen
we should the six is one idea but what
else you can try to do well he wants to
take your Quinn so he wants to take
given Bishop d6 as a possible move but I
the move in the game I think is a little
bit better because my goal in this
position is to get his logical Bishop if
I can get this light square Bishop then
I will have the pair of the bishops
going to be should be six you can just
exchange and probably going to be okay
well you need to move your queen queen
is under attack but you need to find a
good square to move okay because for
example if you put the Queen on d7 this
will be very bad he will just go 95 and
we lose the peace Queen to a5 not so
good 95 and then you take the bishop
because you have to take the bishop
otherwise you down a piece and then he
takes on c6 takes only 7 check and well
here actually you might just be losing
we're back where that's the problem yeah
then it sure takes Bishop takes you can
you can even go back so you just lose
yeah so you have to be careful see there
are some problems which is you can just
move the Queen anywhere and thinking ok
I'm going to get the piece back you need
to put the Queen somewhere that it's not
going to be able to he's not going to be
able to attack again
Queen d8 is a problem with that well you
know he plays here and fork I mean we're
not going to lose a piece in this case
but down upon okay so I got that good
v7 is the right square is not do I want
to go here because then he has a five go
to be seven okay now I'm going to win
the piece back he could try to play
Bishop c4 but then I get some initiative
I take he takes Bishop g4 and he's going
to lose some temples going back and rock
ideas and I think I have you know pretty
nice game here I can play c5 next maybe
but you know maybe close to equal again
but I think I have good development here
so he decided to give up the bishop but
have a little bit more activity so I
played here
I took the bishop and he takes now we
reach this position so what I want you
to I want you to take a look at this for
a few minutes and try to evaluate this
position okay if I say you are playing
this for black what you should be aiming
for it's the worst evaluation of this
position is it equal white is better
black is maybe slightly better what are
the pluses for black well the minus is
just try to evaluate its line okay well
let's think for a few minutes for a few
minutes let's think it's not always just
if the pieces look good then it means
the better you have to also see what
opponent has okay so what opponent can
try to do here so it's a if you just
look here you may think okay white
pieces are more active so it's better
but it's black to move by the way it's
very important
so who you think is better here and work
should be the blacks next plant in this
position now be nice develop the pieces
and connect the rooks okay but the very
important thing you need to try to do
here you have to make sure you don't
exchange one of your bishops because if
you want to get advantage you have to
have your both bishops in this position
because you have the advantage of the
pair of the bishops here okay so that's
a very important thing
so I played ninety-five attacking his
bishop and now he goes Bishop g5 he's
offering the exchange of the bishops
what do you think I should do you
already know I mentioned f6 of course
but f6 yeah not played f6 he went back
and now he's starting to go Knight f5
and take the bishop so he felt like f6
is little bit weakening my position the
weakening c6 square and but the next
plan is very strong and important to
play
you could play queen 86 but he goes
Queenie 4 for example you need to get
you need to prepare you know be prepared
against the move Knight f5 because he
wants to go 95 he wants to get one of
your bishops Taxco bishop or
light-square bishop so you have to try
to do something
you
well tinkly a bit more think little bit
more when you put the rook on d8 right
yeah it's probably okay place but where
do you want to put the rook usually open
file right and you got a magic move the
rook he's going to go Knight f5 your
idea was to move the bishop to f8 there
where do you want to have your rook
imagine that position you want to have
the Rokon detour on e yet right always
really you want to look on an open file
it's very important so you go to key
eight it's very important like it's like
a prophylactic room I see his idea I
make this move so when he comes up I go
here most importantly I keep the pair of
the bishops part on f6 is actually well
placed because it's controlling
important squares so he doesn't have any
attack and now what I would like to do I
would like to play a5 Queen 86 exchange
the Queen's off the board then I have a
very pleasant endgame it's still
probably slightly better but it's much
easier to play for black because I have
a strong light on d5 to bishops and in
some point light squares is going to be
a problem for him because he's missing
that logical bishop and now he plays
Knight f2h for probably an inaccurate
move idea behind it he wants to bring
the Queen to g3 and create some threats
but now I have a very strong sequence
after which I will force the exchange of
the Queen's and get to that favorable
endgame how can you that how can you
force the exchange see if you go Queen
86 you can just go Queen g3 so we can't
really do forced at
remove me seems like a risky move at
first but it's a concrete move you to
calculate
well well he wants to go Queen g3 I
don't want to I don't want to let him go
Quinn g3 because it's quite annoying
then he has this Knight h6 threat and he
has some initiative
to what
yeah you could you could do that but
that's not really going to help us force
the exchange the way I played I forced
him to exchange Queens in just two moves
if I have a Quincy seven he's not going
to go in G three because he doesn't want
to go to endgame he knows he's just much
worse in the endgame with you know maybe
some small chances to hold so he doesn't
want to do that
but his last one was beat upward to a
put the knight on the side of the board
so think about it what can you do
correct correct move g5 now attacking
the knight okay if he plays queen g3
trying to keep the pressure on I just
calmly go here kingly trade and now he
has to sacrifice because he can't just
go back Knight f3 because then I take
the knight so he has to take I take he
takes but he doesn't have sufficient
compensation here because my pieces are
placed very well he doesn't really have
a threat here so all the important
squares are protected I probably just
take on f5 here and think of ideas just
to liquidate he doesn't it may look kind
of threatening a position like this
he's got the Queen to Knights but if you
look carefully can you spot a threat
here for him okay does he have any
threat let's say we pass the turn and
say okay move again can you create a
threat
cf6 is guarded very important g7 g6 so
probably just take they can go something
like rookie six double up the rooks and
think about some exchanging exchange
pieces look g6 so here and do that when
I played g5 here now really regretted
playing this one because now he has to
go back but g5 is a type of wound that
you know you don't expect your opponent
to make it's unexpected you just push
the pawn in front of the King looks like
creating weaknesses but my bishop on f8
is a very important piece one of my best
pieces to Bishop on f8 here not only
guarding d6 also h6 square and now what
is the idea
absolutely queen eight six and now he
cannot move the Queen away because the
knight is hanging see now he has force
now he's forced to take on a6 and that
will allow me another plus is take back
with the bishop develop a piece and gain
a temple c g5 that's a key move in this
game g5 takes Bishop a6
now if I don't everyone we know that
black is better here ready but what do
you think the evaluation is is it
slightly better equal plus or is it
minus plus a big advantage
you think slightly see it's not always
you need to have material advantage to
able to see if it's a small advantage or
big advance sometimes there are
positions you don't even have material
advantage its equal position but
opponent needs to resign for example but
so you think slightly anybody else
mm-hmm
honestly during the game I taught my
advantage is quite significant I thought
have good winning chances and I knew if
I play well I should be able to win this
game because I have pair of the bishops
a very strong knight on d5 and a very
small so very strong pawn here it just
it stops him from advancing his pawns
and he doesn't have any control a and
basically I I have all the play here yes
but then again you don't have a good
plan yeah you can push c4 anyway then I
could use the B file a co-op bound pair
of two rooks take only one you take an
angle route b8 now start entering on a B
file so that's another idea but in this
position I would like to find the next
move a really important move here you
need to find
okay he just played his last one was
look everyone what would you do here
what do you think is the important move
here to play huh aha see remember when
you get into endgame remember it's very
important you get the king closer to the
center well also person it's very
important for you remember things but
also even if you're not dropping a rock
right your piece is already active so
you don't want to just go back attack
something and deactivate the P because
look after you do that you're going to
have to move that piece again so you may
think like you're gaining a temple but
you're going to make your piece worse so
you don't want to do that a tribe is an
interesting idea
g4 gotta be a little bit cautious
because you know at age 4 square C well
his knight is not active on f3 I would
like you to just stay there longer he
stays there better for me because then I
can go anywhere correct very strong move
King answer because you bring the King
into the game 2k takes
you could but I want to do that I don't
want to take and give up the file I want
to keep the tension on and bring my king
up if I want to do it I can do it later
because he's not going to move the rook
away then I go rookie - okay so you move
the king up you still have that idea if
you want to do it but I'm not sure if I
really want to exchange the rooks in
this position I may want to exchange one
pair of the rules but not two
because I might want to use because I
have more activity if actually both
rooks I'm still better but I might want
to keep the rooks one pair of the rooks
okay and this is very important when I
see a lot of games i watch plate I see
if there is an open file players tend to
just automatically just exchange rooks
but you really have to think because in
like in this position I think exchanging
both pair of the rooks would be a slight
inaccuracy for black because you should
exchange one pair of the rooks and try
to create pressure with the other Rock
because his pieces are more active okay
so now I place here
keep it here
now he moved an IPAC now he is trying to
go to e 4 and C 5 C if in snide reaches
on C 5 then I need to make a decision
the night is very strong will attack my
bishop if I take on d6 again I'm a
little bit better but then we enter into
some opposite color bishops and drawing
chances are going to increase so what do
you do here he wants to put the knight
on c5 you don't want to allow that
excellent it has a center upon you
exchange that pawn and that takes away
that idea ok so he takes I take 94
attacking the bishop and by the way
another idea c5 is good here when you
have the pair of the bishops you want to
open the position and that's what c5
does now it's an open board and open
board two bishops are very strong so
they're more effective
oh you mean my night yeah well my night
is still going to be stronger it's not
like he can remove it my main concern is
his night getting to the square I want
to eliminate this square for his night
because I don't want his night to get to
c5 if he had a white bishop to position
so it would be completely different it
will be really a completely different
because then I wouldn't be able to
easily go king f7 I would have to worry
about Bishop age five checks it really
it would be completely different
position here so it's a that's why it's
c5 you have to go this is very important
move so he took I took 90 for activating
the knight now attacking your Bishop
remember I mentioned what is the
importance of having the pair of the
bishops so what do you do now
absolutely I want to put the bishop here
because this would block your work so
you got Bishop f8 and now I have lots of
pressure my rook is very active only
filed putting pressure on my bishop on a
6/9 is good on d5 my next one is going
to be rook c8 putting some more pressure
so he paints here 94 he's trying to get
something going he wants to go Knight f5
96 now
you could go King g6 but now you have a
piece that it looks active but this
piece actually could be on a better
Square and putting more pressure correct
Bishop to b7 see some point when the
time is right I want to be able to move
my knight on g2 and have the pressure
and here we realize the strength of this
bishop okay and I would move my rope
that's coming up soon too but right now
I you know he's already he needs to
worry about some discovery ideas that I
have so very very unpleasant position to
play so he went Knight f2 because he was
worried about some potential discoveries
with my knight so he moved the night
maybe you could have lived an idea but
again I will go to kd8 and very
comfortable for me that position now now
by going back now this will allow me to
activate another piece that I have
Bishop to c5 okay let's see if we can
that looks like we don't have that that
still shows okay okay Bishop c5
activating the bishop of course putting
pressure now only move is c3 and a very
important move you need to find here
black to play what would be the best
move in this position
how they move the root zone ie to
close very close c8 because I want to be
able to take and go look see two very
strong crew kcat not exchanging just
going here because I want him to
exchange because I can I then I can take
back with my rook so now I'm have some
threats of taking and going rook see too
many different threats so he decided to
go back 94 and now see I built up build
up and we got to the position where he
made this move and now you need to find
the winning continuation now to conclude
this game
he was hoping I would go back to a faith
and he would get night at 596 some
threats but he perhaps overlooked what I
can try to do here that would be very
unpleasant for okay that was the point
he wants to have some you know pressure
on me on d6 pawn takes pawn takes my
pawn is strong on before I don't want to
just trade fine tactical continuation
because all my pieces are improved I
think to their you know maximum so here
I have so much pressure so eventually
something should come out yeah for me
okay you know the follow-up
okay well it's it's it's the winning
idea good job also you can just get real
attack of the world okay there you go
very good I took and I took constitute
now I'm down exchange but it's okay now
his night is also week on before if it
just takes back my night then I take the
rook remember I mentioned to you when I
put the pit to put the Bishop back I'm
going to do some potential discoveries
and we see it happen so if it goes away
then I probably have a few ways to win
but I think the simple would be a try
fish just to attack the rook deflect it
and win the night okay so he went back
because you know he's he realized he's
probably losing but at least he wants to
have the extra exchange continue
absolutely he takes
coursed agreed upon now I have two
bishops still two pounds and a very
strong policy tree so going back to c1
it's just very bad so he goes Bishop
Seaton III now what do you do here well
you could do that but at some point
eventually you have to you can't just
keep your bishops all the time so when
you see when you just have to go for it
already
okay you could keep the bishop but then
he takes on a seven I don't know he it's
so in some point you have to already you
can't just keep the best pieces all the
time eventually at some point you're
going to have to don't be too attached
yeah it's good to know when to exchange
them also
well I took he took I played c2 and he
resigned here actually it may seem like
a bit early resignation but in fact he
knew what was going to be my next book
so he has to go probably look to c1 and
now very strong move it's a similar idea
that I'm going to do it's it's the same
idea basically correct rook to DA he can
take the pawn because of the background
checkmate and now you can try to get out
of it by playing King g1 check force the
rook back passive and now what do you do
do you want to exchange the rooks if you
want to keep your rook
now you bring the root of course
protecting your passport and still
threatening still threatening to win
upon now I win the third pond so I will
have a bishop and three pawns and the
most important thing here is no contra
see if he had some kind of conjugate
then I have to worry about but he has no
conscience
so he's going to have to play g3 how do
we win upon in this kind of positions
checking with the rook if it goes to the
corner mate so yes to go here you take
the pawn and still here is no contraband
he can't move the rook up if it moves
the roeckl you have check take so it
goes here and now you simply come back
you don't want to win the Jeep and lose
the c2 pound C to pawn it's very strong
you always want to keep that one and
then you just continue f5 put the bishop
on e4 and then you could win many
different ways you can just push the H
pawn all the way to h2 you can activate
your King to g4 here here well what's
the idea I mean you want to put on d1
yeah I probably I would I would yeah I
would just put the bishop here and just
start pushing I mean here I can go look
G to so anyway as you can see it's
completely losing position so they're
second so my opponent resigned I mean
seems bit early but you know it's at
that point in hearing that I would just
play rock d8 and so i activate my rook
to the second round start winning more
pounds and he can really do anything if
it goes back here trying to just play a
passive defense how would you win this
position
what can you do to win this the most
efficient way to win it I like that I
like the plan with the king to be -
there are many ways to win but I think
King to be - would be the idea that I
would do just get the king yeah I would
probably put the bishop here so you
could do that but the easiest people
would do centralize your bishop
so if it goes here you put the pawn on
f5 and you can put the pawn on f4 and
you simply move the King to be - so and
I mean there really there are so many
ways to win this position but you reach
this position okay and now you're
threatening to take on g2 and go see one
Queen so if it goes here you can just
take and you just Quinn and you two
pawns up in the king opponent game okay
or another idea you could have done is
just simply push the pawn to e5 win the
a four point really this is like so many
ways to win so because the my pieces are
just dominating strong panel see two
strong rook on the two and the bishop on
b7 okay
you